elle est entrée dans l'histoire à 29 ans
francesca schiavone a remporté cet après
midi le tournoi de roland garros elle
s'est imposée en deux sets 6-4 7-6 face
à l'australienne samantha stosur
c'est la première fois qu'une italienne
remporté un tournoi du grand chelem a
longtemps dit michel guillaume le plus
beau jour de sa vie
à 29 ans francesca schiavonne devient la
reine de la terre battue parisienne
pour la première fois une italienne
remporte un tournoi du grand chelem
un pur moment de bonheur pour prendre
ses aises caf et tout son clan merci
merci à tous je pense que sans le
soutien de chacune des personnes qui est
ici je ne serais pas ce que je suis et
je ne ferai pas ce que je fais une
gratuit face à l'australienne stosur la
milanaise 17e joueuse mondiale met toute
sa rage de vaincre à chaque frappe de
balle 6 jeux à 4 dans la première manche
et dire que schiavone n'avait jamais
dépassé les quarts de finale dans un
tournoi majeur jusqu'à cette année dans
le jeu décisif du deuxième set
l'italienne ne tremble pas
l'australienne fébrile traque 7 points à
schiavone peut monter sur le podium
rejoindre la française mary pierce venu
lui remettre le trophée sans frontières
cage où il ya beaucoup d'émotions cela
devra jouer j'aime son attitude sur le
terrain et puis je suis trop contente
pour elle est très sympa le trophée
embrassiez avec amour de retour aux
vestiaires
l'italienne n'était toujours pas
descendu de son petit nuage
moi j'ai gagné roland garros mois
francesca schiavonne j'ai gagné roland
garros et la fête promet d'être belle